-Thank you for being here, pal.
-Thanks for having me here, man.
-You were very nice and
performed on our show before,
which we loved,
but now I get to actually
talk to you, which is fun.
-Sick.
-Yeah, this is sick, right?
-Yeah, that's sick.
-But I'm happy I get to talk to
you and people get to know you.
And I want to recap your year,
if you don't mind.
First of all, you're starring on
the biggest show on TV,
"Euphoria."
Congratulations.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Season 2, the ratings are up
like 1,000% from --
But I'm just saying --
From Season 1.
I'm just saying,
there's a reason why.
-Oh, oh, me?
-Yeah, you're the reason, yeah.
And then you're nominated
for your first Grammy Award.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Not too shabby.
-Sick daddy.
-Yeah, not bad.
-Yeah, I'm psyched.
-And then, you know what
I've got to say?
The coolest thing --
It has to be the coolest thing.
Paul McCartney is, you know,
one of my favorites,
one of my idols.
I love that --
Millions of people do.
"McCartney III" came out.
Great album.
Then he's a genius.
He's like, "I'm going to put out
the new album,
call it
'McCartney III Imagined,'"
with his hand-picked,
favorite new artists --
favorite artists, and they
just do one of his new songs.
And you crushed it, by the way.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You hit a homer.
-Thank you.
Dude...
-You crushed it.
-Thank you.
-What was that like getting the
phone call from Paul McCartney
asking you to be on his album?
-I mean, naturally, like, when
you get a call from anything
that you think is spam, you
block the number, you delete it.
You know what I mean?
-You blocked
Paul McCartney's number?
-Immediately, yeah.
-You didn't believe it was real.
You go, "that's not
Paul McCartney calling."
-I still don't.
I don't even know
if what's happening
right now is real.
-Yeah. You're here.
You're on
"The Tonight Show," bud.
Yeah, we're talking.
-Yeah.
-Are you a --
But that must have been surreal.
Were you a Beatles fan?
-Huge Beatles fan.
When I was a kid, actually,
I got made fun of a lot
for listening to the Beatles.
-Really?
-I grew up in Florida.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, okay.
I don't know what -- They don't
like The Beatles in Florida?
-There's a lot of stuff
they don't like in Florida.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
But then you said, "Hey, no,
you guys got to check out
The Beatles.
They're next level."
-No, I succumbed to
the pressure.
I just started
listening to things like
"Laffy Taffy" and, like, Nelly
and I got through
high school, man.
What do you want me to do?
-"Laffy Taffy." Oh, my God.
But you -- I know you're
working on a studio album.
Okay? Your second studio
album, okay?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know. What can you tell us?
Can you tell us anything?
-I'm actually right up
the road, in Allaire Studio.
The studio's the --
It's, like, the --
Norah Jones recorded her
first couple albums there,
and Bowie has his stuff
all over there.
-Wait. Is that by Woodstock?
Is that Upstate --
-It's right there.
15 minutes away from Woodstock.
-That's where I grew up.
-Stop it.
-No. I grew up -- Yeah, yeah.
You're Florida.
I'm Saugerties, yeah,
Upstate New York.
That's me, man.
I can totally show you where --
Yeah, I could take you to my
parents's house, if you want to.
Yeah.
-Really?
-Yeah, you need anything, man,
you can come stay over
if you want.
Whatever you want, man.
-Anything?
-You need a place to crash, man,
you just call me, man.
I'm your guy.
-So, I have your number, right?
-Yeah, it's under "Spam"
in your --
[ Laughter ]
By the way, I heard that
on the finale this weekend,
there might be a sneak peek of
one of your new songs.
-Where do you hear stuff
like that?
-What are you talking about?
I'm Jimmy Fallon, dude.
I hear everything.
I know everything, man.
-I mean, yeah.
-Well, do you know
anything about it?
-Um...
[ Laughter ]
[ Drumroll ]
No.
-Okay, wow.
Alright, maybe I made it up.
I might have made it up,
but I don't think I did.
But there's stuff on
the Internet
saying that there might be
a new song.
I'm just saying,
that would be cool if there was.
Speaking of what's on
the Internet,
there's a lot of fan theories
about "Euphoria"
and your character.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-And I was wondering if we could
maybe talk about
a couple of the theories
and see if you can hint to
maybe they're true or not.
-Let's do it.
-You play Elliot on the show.
-Mm-hmm.
-One is that Elliot is actually
Nate's estranged brother.
Could that be true?
-I mean...
-No.
-I'm not even going to lie.
I saw this one online.
And I looked at it for a while,
and there were
so many things connecting,
and so many people
were talking about it all
through these Reddit threads.
And at the end of it, I
was like, "Am I Nate's brother?"
-You're like, "Yeah, maybe.
It could be true.
Yeah, it might be..."
-I almost called them up
and asked them, man.
-Okay. Elliot --
Oh, I love this one.
This one, I actually love.
Elliot doesn't actually exist.
He's a figment
of Rue's imagination.
-Oh, my gosh.
You wish.
[ Laughter ]
-Will -- Last one.
Will Tom Holland appear in
the "Euphoria" finale?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tell us. Tell us right now!
Come on, tell us!
-I knew I was going to
hear Tom's name.
-Come on.
Dominic, you can
tell everyone right now,
is Tom Holland on this weekend?
-What I can tell you
is that Tom's
a surprisingly nice guy
for being Spider-Man.
You know, 'cause you assume,
as Spider-Man,
you can do whatever you want.
You can walk into
any room and just
point at someone's girlfriend.
You know what I mean?
Either way...
He doesn't do that.
He points at his girlfriend and
kisses her on the mouth.
And it's nice. It's a good --
Yeah, no, I know. Sweet.
-How's Zendaya?
She's -- How are all the actors?
I mean, do they --
-They're amazing people.
You know, you expect actors to
be a little bit --
They don't tell you as much
about their private lives
as musicians do.
-Musicians just get in there
and tell you everything.
You know everything.
-Well...
-Open book.
-Yeah, yeah, to a point.
-To a -- Yeah.
-Yeah, but actors keep it quiet?
-They do. Don't they?
What do we really know
about you, Jimmy?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know how
to make a sandwich.
That's one thing we learned.
But the show is already
renewed for Season 3.
Do you think we'll
see you back in Season 3?
-Absolutely, yeah.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're going to perform
for us tonight.
-Yeah.
-First, I want to show a clip.
Here's Dominic Fike and Zendaya
in "Euphoria."
Take a look at this.
-You know what I feel like
nobody in my life understands?
Is that, like,
drugs are honestly
the only way I can be myself.
-I-I don't think that's true.
-No, it is true.
Like, when I first met you,
I would have never had
the balls to just,
like, come up to you
and talk to you.
-Why?
-I don't know.
I'm just, like,
a deeply shy person.
And, like, with Jules, right?
Like, when I first met her,
I was just...
immediately in love.
-In love?
-Yeah.
You saying love
kind of sounds small?
-What's a bigger feeling
than love?
-Ah! That's how you
do it right there!
-Yeah, baby. Yeah, baby.
-Dominic Fike, everybody!
Check out Season 2 finale
of "Euphoria,"
Sunday night on HBO and HBO Max.